as the world watches the war russia
brutally started in ukraine
you wonder
how these countries would be different
if the dictator vladimir putin never
took office
who would take control of russia
how would russian people's lives be
different and
would the billionaires get kicked to the
curb
this is what if and here's what would
happen if putin never came to power
so how did this shady figure from the
kgb
become a nightmare to democracy and his
people
well let's step back into the
1990s whoa nice pants
after the soviet union collapsed the
russian economy fell with it almost
overnight
boris yeltsin the first president of the
russian federation then sold off
government-run industries that
controlled natural resources energy
production and construction to a small
group of billionaires
this elite group called the oligarchs
then held 70 percent of russia's
finances
yeah these financial gangsters
bought a nation's economy for pennies on
the dollar
while the oligarchs ran russia into the
ground
yeltsin began searching for his heir
someone to become the next prime
minister
that led him to an ex-kgb official named
vladimir putin after putin got the job
russia waged war in chechnya
and the brutality of that conflict gave
putin his trademark tough guy image
the blood thirsty public loved its new
prime minister and yeltsin passed on the
torch
but if putin wasn't there to answer
yeltsin's call
who would be in charge today
while putin's ego rules supreme in
russia
would his country be different without
him
well if yeltsin hadn't appointed him as
successor maybe these oligarchs would
have fought amongst themselves for the
title
and the top contender oil tycoon and now
exiled ceo mikhail korkowski
when putin took control he made the
oligarchs an offer they couldn't refuse
they'd stay out of politics and he'd
stay out of their business
but horkowski
once the richest man in russia
refused to play by putin's rules
that attitude landed him behind bars
too bad for him he could have taken
control of russia without putin around
so if he and his rich buddies had free
reign today
what would that mean for the russian
people
when putin took office he doubled the
pensions and public salaries
but would the greedy mobsters do the
same
without a central figure leading these
criminals by the nose
these oligarchs might have fought one
another to control russia's assets in a
battle royale for their nation's future
putin already used the army as a
political tool against his enemies and
these madmen also used the total weight
of the military against anyone who stood
in their way
their lust for power could have
endangered an entire country's security
and maybe the world's
the economic sanctions brought on by
russia's illegal invasion of ukraine
strangled russia's economy
the billionaires could soon be brought
down to the common people's level
the poor are happy to see it happen no
matter the cost
but if the upper class had run the
country after the ussr's fall
the russian people might have rebelled
and demanded a change in government
and they may not have asked politely
believe it or not yeltsin and putin once
wanted to join nato
but neither leader would agree to leave
the former soviet republics alone
maybe those political ambitions wouldn't
exist without putin around and russia
might be part of nato today
if russia was pro-western
what would it mean for global trade
when you think of russia's exports your
brain immediately goes to oil well open
up your mind because it's a big country
russia has the largest forest reserves
on earth
but the country only exports a fraction
of what they could produce
an economic boom could have kick-started
russia's economy
instead of pumping all the money into
the military which is what happened
under putin's orders
russia could have made more
infrastructure housing and investments
in education
better roads and more money for
transportation could have opened up the
forest reserves and created a global
demand for russian lumber
that robust economy could have provided
opportunities for more entrepreneurs and
a multi-faceted system built on more
than oil and gas
innovation and globally-minded citizens
might have had a chance to thrive if
putin had stayed out of politics
of course despite a failing economy and
the brutal killing of innocent people
most russians support putin and his
bloodthirsty ambitions
many citizens choose to get their news
from state-run propaganda websites and
television stations
the older generations still have sweet
nostalgic memories of how things were
back in the ussr
maybe without putin manipulating their
minds the russian people would want more
opportunities for themselves and their
families
and fewer endless wars with neighboring
countries
before their war in ukraine the russian
upper and lower classes were miles apart
and poverty was already overwhelming
but now the sanctions and economic
turmoil have led to villagers fighting
in grocery stores over necessities like
sugar
some people have never left their homes
let alone the country
if putin wasn't around and acting like a
cult leader the russian people might
have had their daily needs met instead
of being drained of their resources
instead of being treated like pawns
maybe they could be treated like people
or
maybe the people would idolize the
oligarchs the same way they worship
putin i mean now putin controls the
oligarchs that hold power over russia
but
if their bank accounts continue
shrinking their loyalty could change
overnight
regime change could come at the end of a
gun
now
what would happen if putin died
well
keep watching
because that's a story
for another
what if